take this arm so he can't get his gun
okay all right let's go you guys
slapping clears
uh i don't want to stay in front of him
dude
a skilled dude's not going to stay in
front of me okay
so here's where i'm going to
use that weight and now i have the back
okay and i want this arm over there now
now i have a gun
yeah
oh
coming around
[Music]
i have two choices whoa
first choice is
when he is trying to pass it
you see use that
use your adhesion there he's going to
have a lot of energy coming
trying to get it here so use your
adhesion
and then you have
second one
boom
he got it you see
and he's gonna go for the gun and that's
where you can attack this elbow
first one is there
second one is that when you got it
oh here
step attack
it's right here
okay